this is a catastrophe let me give you
the numbers based upon biden's numbers
they said expect 18 000 people a day
extrapolate that annually that's more
than six million people coming across
the border a year
for texas we get about half of that that
would be the equivalent equivalent of
houston coming across the border in a
year
texas governor greg abbott says his
state is bracing for chaos when title 42
is set to end in just three days in el
paso the town is preparing to declare a
state of emergency over this crisis and
in the big bend sector fox crews filmed
this exclusive video of border officials
capturing smugglers yesterday here to
react fox and friends weekend co-host
will kane good morning to you will
hi ainsley good morning what is texas
doing to prepare we only have three more
days with title 42
well there are several measures
apparently according to governor greg
abbott that texas can put into place he
talked about building a steel wall which
is essentially bumper to bumper cars
along high traffic areas like eagle pass
here's what i think texas should look at
doing ainsley i've become increasingly
interested in this idea of the
declaration
of an invasion if it is an invasion and
we're going to find out as you said in a
matter of three days whether or not that
definition fits then texas can avail
itself of constitutional powers to
enforce the border laws that the federal
government will not that is deportation
that is that is arrest and deportation
the kind of things that states are not
supposedly constitutionally in the past
capable of doing but what we're about to
see
by all expectations ainsley should fall
nothing short of an invasion and if the
bite administration will do nothing
about it in every state texas and
arizona and california need to do
whatever it takes
to protect this absolutely
mind-boggling influx of illegal
immigrants i know that texas is hoping
that this louisiana judge who's looking
at this and we expect a ruling soon to
uh to keep it in place at least for the
next few months so they can figure out a
plan when will we find out that ruling
any word
no but i mean it should come quickly the
judge understands the title 42 is set to
expire on monday so his ruling should
come at any moment truthfully um and on
that note really quickly i would just
say we got to stop looking to title 42
as our savior it was a stop gap it was a
health measure we need to actually
enforce our immigration laws that give
border patrol the ability to do what
title 42 does without title 42. yeah
it's more of a band-aid there's a
quinnipiac poll that says only 26
percent of hispanic americans approve of
joe biden
55 percent supported him in 2021 there's
a large hispanic population where you
live in texas what are they saying
what's the reason for that
isn't that wild that number is
incredible ainsley that is lower than
any other group and i'm not just talking
about ethnic group apparently if you
divide by you know age and education and
any other slice of the onion you want to
pull this is the lowest now why
the answer is the same it is for
everyone ainslie it's the economy it's
inflation it's fuel prices i just fueled
up yesterday ainslie now i have a i have
a truck with a big 36 gallon tank 150
dollars there's work trucks all over
this state all over this country doing
that every week week and a half this is
insane and this is the main motivating
factor for every american regardless of
ethnicity what more i would just add
this there's always been this assumption
in america that latinos somehow embrace
illegal immigration that has been killed
everyone in america regardless of your
ethnic background understands our laws
need to be enforced and the price we pay
if you do not enforce our law from the
streets of new york city to the southern
border of the united states and
hispanics are no different because many
of them did it the right way and they
see these people not doing it the right
way okay so let's talk about the weekend
because you had this you have this
exclusive interview that we're all dying
to see with john paul mack isaac he's
the computer repairman that handed
hunter la hunter's laptop over to the
fbi tell let's watch a little clip of it
and we'll talk about it on the other
side
okay well i called up hunter and said
you need to go out to pick up a hard
drive he picked up a two terabyte he
dropped that off on the 16th i told him
he could come in the next day to pick
everything up i think i called him again
the following weekend and then
i think i called him a couple more times
over the next month after that so just
no response so now i'm in possession of
his laptop
a backup of his
laptop's home folder on an external
drive that he provided
and
it's no sign of hunter
wow and didn't hunter didn't he i talked
to him with you in the green room before
you interviewed him didn't he say that
hunter signed a waiver saying and i
guess you do this when you drop your
computer off you're welcome to look
inside my computer so he had permission
to look at all the crazy stuff that was
on that laptop
yeah and it's inevitable when you're
saving files someone that set for
someone that was his job ainsley and
it was look i got to talk to him for 30
minutes hey 30 40 minutes it's it's
gonna air on fox and friends i'll be on
the will kane podcast it'll be on the
fox news youtube channel he talks about
hunter coming in drunk dropping off
these three devices never returning he
talks about the fbi ainsley the way they
treated him when he tried to turn this
information over to the fbi and then the
way they began to surveil him and how
the whole thing i'm talking media spy
agencies the fbi at the same time
declared him russian disinformation and
what's happened to his life since that
day again when you talk to somebody for
a long time things you get to ask
everything and i asked him everything
including why he wears the balmoral the
hat that he has there on his head it's a
fascinating interview i hope you watch
fox and friends and check out the will
kane podcast yeah he lost his business
when his identity was released too so i
know you talked to him about that all
right thank you we can't wait to watch
it will great job
have a good weekend thank you i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainsley
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis